[Music]
in easy money news
easy money oh I love using money by
Meatloaf's
tail Oh short stubby right now where you
thinner I feel like oh my god happen to
me live I forgot about yourself yeah the
Cho tell scientific word hotel yet poor
baby
it got caught in the door yeah
restaurants are using apps to make big
bucks off of people who aren't eating a
thing
how's that work how do you guys think I
have no idea i'm not scandalous like
that i'm an author you are what the [ __ ]
really yeah think about know they
probably just charging them okay good
for ambience experience i don't know for
the Wi-Fi i don't even know what's
happening restaurants are making money
off of people that aren't eating so how
how do you think they're making cover
charge beverages bathrooms playing games
bathrooms that's 101 that's so dumb oh a
chair just take his [ __ ] seat no it's
like for example in new york there's
this app called lulu app where they
charge between 99 cents to up to five
dollars to use companies or like
businesses restrooms because apparently
they they don't have many public
restrooms in new york and so there's
always people looking for a restroom to
use i believe that okay it makes sense
and then like depending on what how much
you pay for the fee like if you want
just like a stall or whatever then
that's like nine cents but then if you
want like the super bougie restaurants
where there's like lotions and like all
this other stuff than that it goes up to
like five dollars and the restaurants
keep 65 percent of the profit so they
make money off for just letting people
use a restroom so that's one way another
way restaurants are making money is with
this other app called bag B&B where
people just drop off their luggages at
these restaurants kind of like like the
bell desk at hotels and they just make
money off of letting people leave their
luggage there well that's smart to go
yeah
another one it's called kettle space and
that's targeted more for entrepreneurs
or freelancers and it allows like club
owners or restaurants to rent out work
spaces for people so it could be for $25
you can use the space for 10 hours or
$99 a month those are smart yeah they
really got a Maximizer space out there
huh yeah especially with rent going up
like crazy in New York again in New York
but just in general pretty damn smart I
blame the people that [ __ ] up the
restroom experiences in major cities
because San Francisco is really hard to
find toilets too and a lot of businesses
like I think like the cities it gets
harder and harder to find a place to
take a [ __ ] can I blame the people it's
not right because if you go to like
soared Japan Tokyo or whatever they they
have a ton of people the bathroom stay
clean and it's not a problem you know
what I mean like but here oh man I don't
know what it is with people out here man
we [ __ ] up the restaurants I mean the
restrooms how you gonna get Dookie on
the toilet seat man how does your booty
spray Dookie all over the wall exactly
handle [ __ ] everywhere Mike come on man
I'm perfect they [ __ ] like this where
the [ __ ] flies straight like he has a
story of the time that that happened no
I know I know I don't know save see tell
the story hey it's David toilet no I
don't have the be on no I don't all
right I don't fine [ __ ] we won't judge
right now man my eye I flush
I even wiped down with baby wipes I wipe
down the scene no not on me but I hold
my bite cuz I wipe my ass with baby
wives it's a toilet paper cuz I want to
get all this [ __ ] out
do you guys public restrooms you guys
sit down with like toilet paper on the
seat and you take this you know I just
you're not on my routine you I hover
over I stand on the seat I squat squat
though I know I was let's see
demonstration you're the one that puts
shoe marks on the [ __ ] toilet
go ahead he's doing it demonstrate a lot
of agencies
I'm not peeing like this no my mom does
that to she does you taught me how to do
that I go to the bathroom with her what
do you mean nothing this is my mom
stands on the toilet - no she doesn't
maybe before she did but she doesn't do
that anymore I've gone to the rest of so
many times three night check and her
feed you check is bad you're that weird
person in the bathtub looks at his
people yeah he probably felt you
checking so she was like oh [ __ ] she
hears you call back she's like oh
finally in peace man thought then yo did
you guys see that one snapchat of the
guy or the Instagram story where he's in
he's taking a [ __ ] in the kid [ __ ]
says hi what's your name you go the
hitting story that's when you get hit
he's like our youth whatever and then
he's like yeah some get your kid
anything bombs like like that kids
begging to be freaking traffic and he
opened it wide open any laugh oh yeah
one time I was changing and I think I
was at a Walmart or Target and then this
kid just comes into the dressing room
and I'm just like holy crap kids hi are
you my mommy no I'm like can someone get
this kid they were just playing in there
they thought it was fun I hate watch a
kid not you should train title I go
through all the cells underneath Wow
pretty training yeah we have them
crawling all of the [ __ ] public
restrooms right now let us say my place
on the weekends I can undo all that
before you know you're not gonna crop my
child I saw the [ __ ] nastiest [ __ ]
like literal [ __ ] it was pretty gross
like I almost puked so like I was you
know I was flying back to LA over the
weekend right and I had to go to the
bathroom at the Nevada and Las Vegas
Airport and I was [ __ ] taking a [ __ ]
all my phone the whole time didn't know
what was going on and I reach over to
[ __ ] wipe my ass right so I look at
I look at the toilet paper roll and
soaking wet I could see the other man on
like a cross for me there's a [ __ ]
huge hole like that big and I see this
guy rubbing his [ __ ] nuts [ __ ]
hairy as [ __ ] like he's got his like
then I was like oh my god this dude's so
big right is it jacking off no he's
wiping his ass like a woman like threw
his balls like that vagina right here's
what [ __ ] blew my mind okay so
there's two rolls of toilet paper
there's the roll of toilet paper on my
end is down here the second roll is up
here but it's back here on the other
side there's nothing dividing the two
and I'm like looking through and it's
like a toilet paper like toilet paper
roll on that side in the huge space
where I can see the guy I could see his
[ __ ] belly I could see everything and
I'm like if he could if I could see that
he could see me so I was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude like now we're both wiping our
asses together ha ha I saw that he had a
blue striped shirt right so after I was
done we came out and we were washing our
hands because Jess was waiting for me
and we were gonna go look at suitcases
together oh my god could wait like five
minutes and I feel like he saw what I
saw and I was like [ __ ] and we walked
away you go
he didn't say hello they walked away the
good luck at the door to exit
and then they walk out the suitcase
store forever yeah I mean I don't want
to see that you look old I'm like what
the [ __ ] how can I see through this
toilet paper thing you should've an
instant video yeah let me feel my god
amazing dude
he probably has a way different stories
like man I was with this beautiful hair
this asian man and I was looking through
and I was like thank God I could see
through this door and he was like he
kept trying to time everything out with
me every wife was at the same time I
think I met my soul mate yeah yeah it
was nasty hairy as hell too and he wipes
his butt from the butt of his nutsack
through his nutsack I just do as a kid
you know that like you you don't you
wipe the other way you don't do it the
right lane so I write the wipe this [ __ ]
onto my balls
always wiping [ __ ] onto my balls and
then one time like I was just going down
to play with my ball sacks
maybe I should wipe the other direct
yeah cuz I was just wiping hoes are you
at that point I don't remember the
second third grade I was like man I
gotta stop wipe my [ __ ] on to my balls
you guys gotta teach your kids the right
way can you imagine if I reached over
and grabbed the wrong toilet paper and
started rolling it from his side
oh my bro in my hairy bro that'd be the
nightmare I know I was I was shocked
like a [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
damn nightmares about that view you look
traumatized around no he had eyelids he
rubbed his eyes and yet a second eyelid
show up now there happens from time to
time they're gone again is a magic trick
[Music]